off Mark action elvisa Priscilla are
such American legends they're our
version of
[Music]
royalty when I read Priscilla Noir I was
just struck with what an unusual wild
ride her life has been it's a long
story I know so much about all this and
it was really important to me to show
the story through Priscilla's
experiences I've seen all of her movies
and sensitivity her understanding of
women she puts her heart and soul in it
I would never do this with anyone
else I love to be immersed in someone
else's world 60s Memphis so Americana
some world that I've never really
explore you could really relate to all
the things that she went through the fun
of it and also the struggles and the
isolation she just got me and I trusted
her thank
you